so since 2005 i've chosen words for the
year every year i have a word there's a
campaign and there's a ward and then
quarterly there's a word that i have as
well
on what i focus on if there is a word
that you ought to make
as a key word to follow the next 90 days
september october november the word is
anticipation today i'm going to share
with you
15 potential things that can happen
pre-election time
so before i get into my 15 points let me
preface this the reason why these times
are different than ever before is the
following reason you ever been out of
dinner
and you're with six friends okay you're
with eight friends
and these eight friends politically
they're this far apart some are
democrats some are republicans some are
independent but they're this far apart
or when it comes down to sports some are
lebron guys some are jordan guys some
are kobe guys
but they're this far apart you know how
dinner's gonna go it's gonna be a civil
dinner
but a big but have you ever gone to
dinner or a gathering and you know
people are coming over
and you have friends that are this far
apart
you know what happens if the
conversation of politics or sports comes
up
boom eruption now take that
and put the media today to where they're
presenting everything to the world
we're not this far apart we're not this
far apart not this far apart
what the media is showing they're only
highlighting people
who are boom so far apart
that it's making everybody feel like
it's the end of the world
the first thing to look out for is the
amount of divisiveness
media is going to use the next 90 days
it's going to be
so havoc as bad as you've thought you've
seen it it's going to be worse that's my
first point for you to be thinking about
that could happen pre-election the level
of divisiveness with the media as bad as
it's been it's going to go to
new heights number two major protesting
rioting worse than what we've ever seen
if you thought you saw protesting happen
it's going to get worse and
you know it's going to be scary in some
areas which we'll talk about here in a
minute that's number two
number three more potential
george floyd stories to come out more
potential just yesterday
there was one in wisconsin man was shot
on the back
protesting took place rioting took place
just so you know
that's going to be more and more of
these stories not that it doesn't happen
but it's going to be specific stories
that the media is going to choose the
media is not going to choose the other
way around story of a four-year-old
white kid being shot by
an african they're not they're only
going to use stories that can divide
america because it's more eyeballs
more advertising you have to be aware of
this that there's gonna be more stories
so here's how the media works
they sit there and they say okay what
stories do we have what stories do we
have
we have this story what happened here
this four-year-old kid got shot and he
was oh no we can't use that that doesn't
match our narrative what story do we
have here here's the story the story
here we have is
on the right and the left here's the
story we have here's a this this
african-american man is uh a a major
supporter of trump if it's fox they say
what oh this is great let me use it
because it's good for them right
now here's the other one here's a former
republican who is now
anti-trump oh let me use this right but
the george floyd type stories
are going to be picked up at levels
we've never seen before because today
it's part of the narrative number four
more volatility by the market you're
going to see more volatility volatility
taking place
because some people are simply going to
sit there and say i have no idea what's
going to be taking place when a buffett
spends 561
million dollars in gold and he's never
done it before
he's sending a message to the world when
a buffett is sitting on a 147 billion
let me say this again i'm going to be
saying this so many times because it's
anticipation
when a buffett is sitting on 147 billion
dollars of cash let me put it to you
this way berkshire
hathaway is roughly a 490 billion dollar
company okay give or take
500 billion auto company out of the 500
billion dollars
147 billion of it is in cash you know
how many people are doing that
what do you think berkshire hathaway and
all the brilliant investors that they
have on that team what do you think
they're assuming and anticipating
just think about that let me say one
more time 561 million dollars in gold
147 billion dollars in cash what do you
think they're thinking
you you think this is maybe a time to
kind of let's just kind of watch and see
what's going to be taking place
because things could get very ugly and
this is buffett who we're talking about
right
so more volatility number five pressure
causing new people to step down and
separate themselves
from somebody they're associating
themselves with meaning uh oh
clintons are getting too much heat i'm
no longer associating with them uh oh
you know trump man my daughter is kind
of giving me a hard time kellyanne
conway i got to step away because
kellyanne conway's daughter i don't know
if you know who she is
she is causing mayhem in her life
with her father and her being against
trump etc etc and they're trying to kind
of make it work
so kellyanne conway steps down and says
i'm going to go
and focus on my family a day before rnc
there's going to be many of these
stories taking place the next 90 days
a lot of pressure pressure pressure
they're going to use it through
kids family spouse a lot of people
distancing themselves
from certain people because of exactly
that number six
schools could potentially get shut down
every time we go to school all these
different schools we're going to
whether i'm interviewing schools in
florida here no matter where it is in
dallas
even our school it's good to be open we
went through three different teachers
for our kids right you know what every
one of them says
we're gonna go like this but who knows
it could shut down again who knows it
could shut down again
they all said it that's part of the
script which means the principal told
them you ought to prepare the parents
that
it could shut down again why are they
saying that because there's probably
another organization they're talking to
that's telling them
it could shut down again which means
schools
could shut down again if anticipation is
the key word for the next 90 days and
schools
shut down again are you prepared for it
because that could potentially happen
again number seven
vaccine talks going to continue to go to
a whole different level i know recently
you know bill gates was hammered by one
of the reporters i think it was from cbs
or abc
where the lady said 80 of people that
are taking this vaccine that we're
testing on is getting
extreme reaction to it what do you have
to say about that and he had 10 seconds
of no answer he didn't know what to say
vaccine talks going to go to a
completely different level
be prepared for that that's going to get
more heated you're going to see trump
and fi
you know fausty going at it it could be
a whole different name of people coming
in he could get fired somebody else
could come
all of these things could be taking
place number eight new leaders are about
to be identified
every time there's crisis leaders are
born i don't know why this is the case
it's always the case
be prepared for a lot of new names you
didn't know about before like this to be
identified so wait
i didn't know that person wow new leader
being identified
kovid gave birth to more hours
of tv time for cuomo than ever before
cuomo's been on tv more the last four
months
than he's been on his entire life
everybody around the world now knows the
name cuomo why
because there's opportunities for new
name and new leaders rise up you're
going to hear some names you're going to
say
no idea who this guy is now he's on tv
every single day before fausti was on tv
every day did you know who fausti was
no before you understand what i'm saying
it's going to happen even more as we're
continuing so
be prepared for that potential cancer
debates debates could be cancelled
debates could be taking place from biden
sitting at his house
and trumping somewhere and they're
debating on zoom and biden's being fed
answers on what to say and it's going to
be it could go that direction just be
prepared for it it's going to be a very
very interesting
direction we may be going to with
debates being cancelled so be prepared
for that
and how much scandal that's gonna bring
if debates get canceled we typically
have three debates
if if if people are betting right now in
las vegas most people are betting
there's not gonna be three debates it's
probably gonna be two
they're hoping for one if i go to one
i'm giving you the middle finger but you
get the idea
they're going to one debate but it's
most likely gonna end up being two
they're saying we're gonna have three i
think it's gonna end up being two we'll
see what
happened the right wants to have three
debates the left wants to have
one debate you get the idea there okay
next
number 10 more wealth is going to be
made
how do these go together pat during
times of crisis
those who are poised make a lot of money
because there's a lot of opportunity
there the media can
bash all the billionaires they want a
bash they want
but the difference is they know how to
make money during good times and bad
times it's what makes them
be on the cover of magazine if you only
know how to make money during good times
no wonder the world doesn't know your
name this is also an opportunity because
you're going to see some of you guys are
watching
oh my gosh what if this happens
everything pat is saying this sounds
scary
it's also opportunity it's always been
the case it's never changing this is a
time for you to also capitalize for your
own family and say look i know what's
happening let's be prepared
but at the same time let's figure out a
way how we can also expand our business
to the next level
next point number 11 news stories that
are being kept
will be used last minute what do i mean
by that
you're going to see epstein's stories
jelaine maxwell stories coming up
insider people on biden's camp new women
coming out about
against biden stuff coming out against
kamala stuff coming out against
pence and trump a lot of stuff that's
coming already on them but there's going
to be more
tapes and you know recordings and video
stuff
oh my gosh that stuff is going to come
out and it's being kept but you better
believe they're keeping it to use it the
last month pre-election
it's going to be a very interesting time
to use all this stuff just be prepared
for it you will have the most
entertaining month coming up here very
soon
and i'll talk about it on monday what
the most entertaining month of the year
is going to be
next certain states and cities
will play more games than others meaning
i'm a california guy 20 22 years minus
the two years i was in the army
i love the state of california every
time i go back to california my dad
calling my dad when i see where he's
living and my sister's doing a video
saying there's a hundred homeless people
that says what are you talking about
i've never i lived with my dad for eight
years we lived together with roommates
i've never seen homeless
people in that area hundreds of homeless
people laying out
okay areas in california that used to be
clean nothing homelessness
everywhere san francisco high end you
would go
everywhere california you you're going
to have some interesting things happen
with you
with what garcettis and newsome are
going to decide to do it's going to be
very weird
new york city i don't think new york
state meaning buffalo upstate i don't
think
but i think new york city de blasio
prepare yourself the other day he had to
make an argument why his wife
is getting a 1.1 million dollar salary
and he was making an
argument why his wife deserves to get a
1.1 million dollar salary
new york city is going to get a lot of
heat coming soon here
and it's going to affect the people so
the good thing about new york city is
california garcity is newsom is above
them right they're on the same page
but de blasio the good thing about new
york is at least cuomo is reasonable he
knows
he needs business it's the difference
between the two portland's going to get
weirder
oregon is going to get interesting
illinois brace yourself chicago get
ready
some city is going to get them more than
others and
it's it's gonna be the the most the most
relevant word to use in a time like this
that relates to this is interesting
that's all i can tell because it could
go so many different angles we're gonna
see what's gonna happen there
but those cities be prepared for dc as
well by the way it's going to get a
little weird number 13
new political stars are going to be born
whether it's media
whether it's working on the news whether
it's a 22 year old person coming out
and that leads to my next point which is
point number 14 major major viral videos
you're going to see
videos that get 100 million views 82
million views
you know candace owens did a video and
it got 18 million views with a 24 hour
you know it got 50 million views i think
within 24 hours on facebook and it was
an 18 minute video it wasn't like it was
a three minute video rant it was an
18 minute video you're seeing more
videos like this of aoc are gonna go
viral more aoc videos are gonna go viral
a lot of viral videos and new stars will
be born
like pre you know these aocs and tammy
lawrence and the charlie kirk and all
these names and the candace owens and
all these names that you're seeing they
all of a sudden became
household names that people know about
and they're speaking at both camps i
think charlie's speaking at rnc
aoc spoke at the dnc
you're going to see that times 100
right now because the more heat
gives more opportunity for new stars to
voice their opinions
to be shared more so expect your feed to
have new voices going viral like this
and last but not least
major major issues with the post office
major major major issues with the post
office
trump may shut it down the other side
pelosi is trying to fund them and give
him 25 billion
trump shuts it down there's not going to
be mail-in ballot the way they want to
do it on so that that part is going to
be a
very some are saying manipulation is
taking place while election
some are saying we've been doing this
for a long time what's the big deal
regardless of it all
i think it's going to come down to that
because goldman sachs is saying this is
the type of election that could be
a a recount that could call more than
the al gore bush one that lasted i think
32 days this is one that can go for a
long time and we may not know
who's going to be president for a long
time or it could be an easy one
boom done it's over with but this is
what i will tell you
no matter what happens remember blood is
blood
what do i mean by blood is blood i don't
like seeing
families having their political beliefs
and the fights come in public i don't
like it what do i mean by that
i don't like seeing siblings coming out
and you know they're bashing each other
and one's a republican once
and they're involved in politics i don't
like that
because it's blood blood has history to
it especially if you've lived together
it's a different story if you're step
brothers
and you've never lived together and one
was raised in a whole different family
you weren't
and you have opinions about your
stepbrother that did something i totally
get i'm talking about if you live
together
grew up together like stuff you're
seeing with family
keep this idea in mind before you debate
anybody that's a friend or family when
it comes on to politics the next 90 days
it's a rule of thumb to use 42
of america americans are republicans
they're going to
vote republican down the aisle can't
change their minds 42
no matter what 44 of democrats are going
to vote democrat you cannot change
the 44 percents mind you cannot change
the 42 percent's minds
and you cannot change the four percent
that's gonna go green green
and libertarian right you only have ten
percent of people that you can
influence their mindset when you're
talking to people before bringing up an
issue
always start like this john are you open
to vote in a different way if the right
argument is made oh
hell no don't waste your time
i'm just telling you don't waste your
time
okay it because that relationship
could be ruined by you trying to force
someone that's not going to change their
they're 40 they're not going to change
but if you have a 10
group that's reasonable and it's willing
to entertain a good conversation
then go at it but not if somebody is not
going to change your mind
it will ruin relationship it will ruin
friendships
and will divide the household and it
simply ain't worth it here's why
because in the next six twelve months
it's gonna be over with and we will not
have another one of these ugly things
for another four years so the next 90
days woosa as much as you can
be patient as much as you can do your
best as much as you can
if you're a true believer on your side
of the politics try to convert as much
as you can
through reason through respect through
data rather than name calling
because that philosophy and approach is
simply not going to work having said
that
these are the 15 things that could
potentially happen pre-election i got a
video i want you to watch
that has to do with another prediction
it's a video i made two years ago
and i talked about 10 industries that
could potentially experience a
disruption
even an extinction and if you watch this
video from two years you're gonna say oh
my gosh it's as if these ten industries
are all going extinct today if you've
not seen it click over here to go watch
that episode
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so have a great week
everybody take care bye